à kampala après plus de 24 heures les
passagers de l'airbus d'air france ainsi
que l'équipage prise en otage à athènes
ont été débarqués de l'avion mais ils
sont rassemblées dans une salle de
l'aéroport est toujours sous la
surveillance des pirates de l'air le
maréchal hanine dada présence au
l'aéroport d'entebbe même
personnellement les négociations à
l'heure actuelle on ne connaît pas les
conditions demandées dans les pirates
ils seraient au nombre de cinq et se
réclameraient du front populaire de
libération de la palestine
il semble que le maréchal idi amin dada
a négocié dans le sens souhaité par les
français c'est à dire pour obtenir la
libération globale de tous les étages
lorsque l'airbus d'air france décolle de
bengazi hier soir vers 22 heures c'est
pour une destination inconnue seule
certitude l'appareil ne dispose que de 6
heures de carburant on croit d'abord
qu'il se dirige vers amman en jordanie
c'est la radio israélienne qu'il affirme
de son côté l'aéroport d'athènes fait
savoir que l'airbus a survolé la région
de khartoum au soudan et l'egypte qui
précise que son territoire n'a pas été
survolés ajoute que la destination
choisie par les pirates de l'air
pourrait être aden au sud yémen
en fait après avoir quitté benghazi
l'avion s'est effectivement dirigé vers
khartoum mais il est ensuite descendu
vers kampala en ouganda où il s'est posé
ce matin à 3h40 heure de paris c'est un
colonel de l'armée ougandaise qui le
premier a entamé les pourparlers qui
seront ensuite poursuivie par le chef
d'état ougandais et qui ont permis pour
l'instant aux passagers de quitter
l'avion pour gagner l'aérogare où il
reste sous la garde des terroristes
alors pourquoi un appareil français
détourné ce qui n'était jamais arrivé au
proche-orient d'après radio kampala les
pirates estime que la france a toujours
été l'ennemi des arabes de charlemagne
est à giscard d'estaing en tout cas
cette action paraît être l'oeuvre d'un
groupe appartenant au front du refus
palestinien qui n'écarte pas
l'utilisation de telles méthodes pour
régler le problème
la palestine six minutes